we return to our phone lines for our
latest guest i just want to say this
uh you know how in the sports world um
when there's uh a big game that's hyped
it's very rare
that the game lives up to billing
correct chris
or a player needs to have a big game and
then that player actually has the big
game
very rare so my wife and i we spend
literally we're lucky our children still
get to go to school because that's how
much we spent on the tickets for
hamilton about five years ago
uh four or five years ago and uh where
we heard so many things about it
and we're like okay you know we're
trying to you know lay back a little bit
because we don't want our expectations
to be ruined
because so rare does it me does it meet
i'm talking about
anything i've ever seen live ever i'm
talking about a concert
a rock concert anything does not compare
to
having seen hamilton live on broadway
with the original cast that i've seen
we've also seen here in los angeles it's
it's it's a perfect
perfect musical and it means so much
also for our country and talking about
what our country's all about it is just
remarkable the music is amazing the
performances are amazing
and it's going to be back uh the the
original cast uh for
a film of of hamilton they filmed it
with the original cast and that's going
to be on disney plus uh
july 4th week that's going to be amazing
and he
plays lafayette and jefferson in that
production
and he is also in tnt's snow piercer
that is going to debut this coming
sunday it's already been renewed for a
second season
david diggs here on the rich eisen show
how are you sir
hey man i'm i'm doing well great to talk
to you
great to talk to you i'm a big fan of
your work i don't care if just walking
through the door
and just starting the interview that way
that that's a fact oh man
i i appreciate that very much i mean you
must hear that a lot from people that
have seen
uh hamilton and you part of that
original cast
yeah it really struck a chord with
people um and
yeah i'm very i feel very fortunate to
be a be a part of it you know
i've i've been friends with lynn um lin
manuel who wrote it in tommy kale for a
very long time
um and so for me that process was just
the same as everything else i've ever
done like making something you think is
cool with your friends but
i've done that a lot and nobody else
seems to think it's cool but then this
one
everybody everybody agreed with us
so um yeah it's i feel very fortunate to
have been a part of it all right let me
just geek out a little bit more on on
this before moving on to sports and your
current projects
um when did you realize when did you
realize this one in particular was
special when did you realize that this
uh uh when this was uh off the charts
david well like i said i i knew it was
special as soon as lynn sent me his like
rough demos with him singing every song
uh every part of every song hold on a
second wait
are you that's how you were introduced
to the the music the score the book the
whole thing
yeah tommy had said hey would you tommy
kale who directed that
they were going to do a reading up at
vassar and would i would i come out and
and do some stuff with them and i i
asked if he was going to pay me and he
said yes
i said of course then and
and then um yeah lynn sent me his demos
which were literally like garageband
click tracks with him you know at rough
like sort of piano sketches of some of
the melodies and him singing every part
uh and i was like this is it's brilliant
these songs are absolutely brilliant
even even in this very rough form
so again like i knew it was special that
doesn't mean that it's gonna
hit you know those things don't often
more often than not don't line it up
so why do you think it it it resonated
then
um a lot of reasons it is just that good
you know in terms of like a piece of
of art it also was handled really
carefully um one of the things that the
whole all of the producers
um jeffrey teller and and and tommy kale
as well
as the director we're really careful
with how it was
allowed out into the world i think a lot
of things
hurry out when they when people know
something's good you get so excited and
you rush to put it out we
we've workshopped that for three years
before
it ever had a you know was on a stage
and then we went downtown for a while
and then you know everyone was begging
for it to go to broadway anyway but
we really took the time to develop it
and i think that
that's part of the secret to us and then
also that time in our you know
we lost barack obama's presidency you
know we
we sort of saw that in the future too
there was a kind of um
new buy-in to the american experiment by
a lot of people
um and the show was sort of
representative of that
so uh and then before we move on here um
when you're on a hit show
uh on broadway like that um
and the the people that you must have
met
uh backstage after a show name drop
who's the one that you were like i can't
believe this person is backstage telling
me about what a great performance we
just had
honestly i mean and we you gotta
understand like i met
everybody like everybody you name a
famous person that came to the show
so many incredible artists who i admire
i have never been more starstruck than
when i met
empty hammer for the first time
well i mean it's oakland that's that's
your oakland connection right there
and it and it took me right back to
being a kid
and seeing him on tv and thinking oh i
could do that you know like he
it was it was that was the first tape i
bought with my own money was please
hammer don't hurt him like i
like i yeah that was the most starstruck
i've been and now like we we text like
he's if i still can't believe
that he's in europe he's so you and m so
is he
is he how is he in your in your phone is
it mc is it mch
what are what are the how is he in your
phone
i think it's just i think it's just
hammering my phone just hammer
way to go david that's now that's a nice
flex right there certain
heads of state are probably back there
you probably did meet barack obama you
probably didn't meet the president in
the first place many times
i mean obviously that's like you know
them having us out to the white house
the wildest experience of my life but uh
but i you know what about sports stars
what about any sports stars that you
might have met back there
oh yeah um i mean god
so many uh magic came through okay i
remember
i was actually the show was
i don't the show was was in san
francisco
um when when steph saw it for the first
time i think but
me and like i have me and steph curry
have
done a few things together since then he
was such a fan of the soundtrack and
then saw the show when it was in san
francisco
but we met it's another con and it
happened via hamilton
anyway that that's a big one for me what
about marshawn lynch if you want to go
oakland is lynch is money lynch everest
you're you ever i don't know i don't
know if you've seen it
i don't know i don't know you're more
likely to see lynch at his
store on broadway you know like i bet so
this is religion
you know like you got hard to find i
know right i mean and he
he's just he's remarkable i mean that
guy is truly
about it in terms of oakland and you
know it's
it's interesting too i got to v diggs
here on the rich eisen show about what a
lush
sports history of that town and
obviously the raiders are now in vegas
the warriors are now across the way i
mean
your team would be would be which is it
the warriors is that your team
david yeah yeah definitely the lawyers
um for forever always been the warriors
even when it was hard to be a warrior
right and that would be pre-steph
pretty much right
you're referring to your pre-staff error
oh
sorry i lost you for a second yeah
priest steph is the is the tough
uh is the tough warriors yeah yeah yeah
yeah pre-staff freeze-tastic
but yeah the directly pre-staff when we
were like training camp for great
players that would go elsewhere that was
uh
those were tough years davey diggs here
on the rich eisen show let's talk about
um snow piercer um and
it's based on the film um which was the
um first hollywood film written and
directed by
uh bong joon ho who is
i guess the what would you did you win
five times for this academy award season
for parasite
pretty much i like it oh man i don't
the man of the year in in the film
industry for sure
so what was it like uh uh doing the show
i'll give you the floor and what uh what
we're about to see on tnt sunday night
david
yeah it's a it's a wild show man it's
it's um
set seven years post day uh
an apocalyptic uh climate event in which
the whole world freezes over and
everyone that's left alive
is a passenger on this train called
snowpiercer
that uh keeps everyone alive as long as
it keeps moving
so the train can't stop um and some
people paid a lot of money for their
tickets and they exist in first class
and as you make your way back
towards the back of the train i could
afford
less and less comforts on the train all
the way to the tail where my character
andre layton is from
who was part of a group of of
stowaways essentially who boarded the
train violently in order to save their
own lives right as it was taking off
and have been allowed to remain there
but enjoy
none of the comforts of of the train uh
and so yeah it's a my fear was also a
um a homicide detective piece and
the instigating incident for the show is
that there was a there's a murder
up on the train so they have to come
back and get laid out to help solve this
murder
and that will be debuting at 9 eastern
time on tnt
on sunday night and then you're in a new
animated musical sitcom that's
premiering
the last friday of this month on apple
tv called central park and
uh another colleague of yours from uh
from the original hamilton cast leslie
odom jr
and then two frozen colleagues and josh
gad and kristen bell as part of this as
well
what is this show about it's it's great
so it's um yeah it is a musical
about centers around family who are the
the father of the family voiced by
leslie odom jr is a are the
groundskeepers of
of central park um and
i played i've always
sent to kind of the villain of the show
named hughes voiced by stan
um and they are trying to take over the
park
and uh essentially put a call in it
they're trying to figure out a way to
park um it's incredible the music is so
much fun
when i tell you leslie out of juniors i
mean he's he's amazing and everything
but
he's a good friend of mine and i didn't
know he could do this
his his voice acting in this are is so
so
good so funny i'm i'm very excited for
everyone to see it well then again
on apple tv plus on may 29th and then on
disney plus on july 3rd
uh the hamilton film um i mean
you how many performances of hamilton
did you do
david what would be the number
oh uh i i don't know countless
a lot over over 500. 500. so would you
is it would you even be curious just to
watch this back
as a film i mean is that something that
you're you're eager to see it's been
something i know that fans of this uh
of this musical is is ready to ready to
see
i'm just wondering how it would be for
you i am very yeah i'm very happy
that everyone else is going to get so
much joy out of it i'm mostly terrified
i think why one of the one of the things
i love about theater is that i never
have to see myself
do it um so and for this to be as
you know i mean you talked about in the
intro how hyped up it was like
i have been living with that now for for
four years since i left
with people talking about this
performance of mine that i've never seen
and that's probably the only reason i
can't even
stand that kind of phrase i don't like
watching myself
so uh i'll just shut my eyes when i'm on
stage well david if you need if you need
any help
um with that uh i watch myself every day
um and yeah you know i have no problem
um but then again the name of my show is
is on it um there is an eye in both my
first and last name
i do feel like i'm a team player but and
and take my word for it you're fantastic
in it so don't worry about it it's gonna
be an easy watch back for you
i appreciate you so much thanks for the
time and good luck with snow piercer and
uh when we uh can have in studio guests
again i would love to have you certainly
when an nba season is back and we can
talk warriors we can talk all that good
stuff
be great i would love i would love that
let's definitely do it right back at you
david diggs on both twitter and
instagram right here on the rich eisen
show the tony and grammy award winner
doesn't want to watch himself back i'll
tell you
he'll be fun hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here